Hello everyone, Neal Browne with Bill Decker in the International Business Minute.
Bill, a lot of people have their company, they want to expand overseas,...
...they have the best intentions but they make a lot of American faux pas,...
...not even knowing what they're doing.
That's right, Neal, I'm making one right now.
If you look at the way I'm sitting, I'm pointing the bottom of my foot directly at you,...
...which throughout the Muslim world, throughout the Buddhist world and several African countries,...
...this is the dirtiest and most unclean part of the body and I'm pointing it directly at you.
Offending you, it's tantamount to cursing you out.
And Americans would just say, "I'm getting comfortable, I'm crossing my legs".
"What's the big deal?"
Well, exactly, and culture is that way.
Culture is very personal, culture is very local.
Here's another one: the two-handed handshake which we do in America...
...to show how much we appreciate meeting people.
Yes.
In the Muslim world and the same world I mentioned, this is the bathroom hand.
This is the hand we use in the bathroom.
So by ingratiating myself to you and touching you,...
...I've actually nauseated you and hurt my chances of doing business.
So Americans don't even know that they're making insults all the time...
...without them being conscious.
And advice is available.
And very good advice to know.
Neal Browne with Bill Decker in the International Business Minute.
We'll see you next time.